hello Reba for this Chris hello Reverb
[Music]
now I'm this
I'm busy attitude
and they require some mental fortitude
[Music]
let me Preserve
[Applause]
let me preserve I'm tired
r-e-s-p-e-c-t clean
[Music]
15 years old believing life really sucks
kinship Cara I could stay with my mom
social workers in the drama I vow to
overcome I need it long I vowed to
overcome social workers in the job
that's why if she says I'm perfect I
don't know if she sprung or she's trying
to get to my head like shots of Jameson
look at the monks that I've become
Africa
[Music]
and now I'm displaying attitude
and they require some mentally fortitude
I'm tired
[Music]
I can see now when opticians
they're covering up personal ambition
I'm covering with Hustlers Ambition
there what they were now to support the
mission neither that in Seven Sisters
back the limited edition
I'm modeling God's grace and wisdom good
thing I use interview intuition is who I
did not precisely mathematician no
petition Car Craft put into fruition
[Music]
no collisions
thematic behavior I'm not feeling
friction let me just mind my business
optimistic
he ain't Christian
traffic killer bust it now that's
traffic skrilla one extra in 10 pound
slippers
they require some men to fortitude
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
r e s p e c t